rage on the streets of Belgrade as
anti-government protesters call for new
elections a crowd of thousands of people
tried to storm the city hall building
but they were pushed back by a riot
police people pushed the door very hard
suddenly the door caved in and at the
same moment a large formation of police
showed up with shields and anti-riot
Equipment the center left oppos ition
Alliance Serbia against violence has
refused to accept last week's
parliamentary and local elections which
International observers say were marred
by vote buying ballot stuffing and the
improper influence of President
Alexander vuic the results mean his
governing Serbian Progressive Party
holds a parliamentary
majority the president has condemned the
attempted violent
takeover for days we warned of this
alerting International parties many were
refusing to acknowledge what was being
planned our intelligence Services
responded knowing exactly what the
troublemakers were plotting we won't let
them destabilize our
country activists accuse police of using
excessive force thousands of people have
been
arrested Serbia is grappling with a year
of political unrest sparked by
demonstrations against mass shootings
which involve into protests against
Rising inflation and allegations of
government
corruption Axel zovich Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer